tony abbott do you think that your
colleague the health secretary misspoke
yesterday when he said that what he
actually said was what
the what he inferred was that because
he was good at trade we could forgive
his antecedents
i didn't see the uh of course you did he
did six million views on do you want to
see it
sorry absolutely let's have a quick look
you've got it
just told you what he said i'm sure you
don't support some of his comments
he's a homophobe and he's a misogynist
well uh he's also an expert in uh trade
so that's all right then well look i i
as far as i'm aware there haven't been
any announcements made on this at all so
i think we should wait till we
um get an announcement one way i'm
asking you about
tony abbott and whether you feel that
your colleague misspoke when he said
that it was okay
for him to be a misogynist and a
homophobe reportedly
because he's good at trade well as i say
i i don't want to sort of get in
something where i haven't
he hasn't been announced as whatever
this trade position is
um i haven't studied the tony abbott
record unless the first time i've seen
uh matt hancock um talk about it so i
know these things get sort of
blown up and sometimes sort of you know
become a very big kind of issue here but
if if if he hasn't been announced and uh
you know i haven't personally seen all
of his
comments personally speaking you know i
don't think in in uh
you know modern society i think people
should respect each other and i don't
think
we um you know i think we we know
the standards by which we would you know
have conversations
but um you know you're inviting me on
something which i'm afraid i'm not
a worldview shouldn't you be i mean if
he's going to be representing us
um around the world well and that's the
big question if he's going to be so why
don't we wait well don't we need to know
i'll come back i will come back
i'm sure you will but i've got you here
now so i'm going to press you if i may
um he may be given that he is a climate
change denial
given that he has said some despicable
things about the elderly and
it didn't matter if they died of kevin
19 they should die naturally
given that he talked about women and
ironing and
some of the views on whether they should
succumb to sex
or not and given some of the views he
said about her homophobic that basically
homophobic views
would you be happy to have a drink with
that man well as i say i mean you're
inviting me to sort of comment on
somebody who
because i wouldn't be happy to have a
drink with him would you well i've never
been invited
well i prefer first of all i want to
check the record for myself i'm afraid i
have to admit i haven't had time to to
to do that um and secondly
i i hate to bring us back to reality he
hasn't been appointed to anything and as
far as there haven't been any
appointments made so let's wait and see
and i promise i'll come back on your
program
i'm never shy of coming on your program
i'll come back and talk about it if it's
actually interesting and you don't feel
that you're dodging that question well i
simply
you know you're asking me things which
are very abstract in as much as nobody's
been appointed to the positions
he's certainly being considered and he
pretty patel was courting him we saw
pictures of her with him and liz truss
is also very keen on him taking up the
role well i don't think that somebody's
with the fact that somebody's met
somebody is is proves that somebody's
posing for photographs in the home
office
well as i say i'm not sure that actually
proves anything apart from the fact he
you know is was a a world leader of uh
uh you know a major economy
and uh and uh economic and social friend
of ours in australia but uh yeah i know
you're trying to draw me out on this i
promise
i will come back as i said to your
colleague yesterday you know you're a
forward-thinking 21st century man do you
really want to be associated with some
of this kind of well as i say there are
lots of people
with whom their comments i would uh very
disagree but i'm not into defending
people who are not actually carrying out
any role for the
british government there's no reason for
me to comment on it until or unless
and i promise you i'll be back in your
studio
at least i tried